Now that we added this favoriting mode, we can also change the class here a little
bit based on our favorite status,
so that we have a green button when the next action is to turn this into
a favorite,
and this reddish button if the next action is to actually turn it into, well, the
unfavorited status again.
and for that on the button component i'll actually accept a new property and you can
name this
whatever you want i'll name it color here and set this to null initially now color
can be success
because i already prepared a class for this and we can now go to the class
here on the button and
simply add another expression in there where we also add color now color either is null
in which
case a class with the name of null will be added which simply has no effect
or if we choose success
success will be added and actually i did define styles for success buttons and also for
outlined
success buttons so hence now if we go back to the meetup item where we use
the button
we're setting a mode, which is great.
I now also want to set a color
and this color is based on whether
we're having a favorite here or not.
So again, I'm checking isFav
and if we do have a favorite,
then the next action is to unfavorite,
which is of course not that great.
So then I wanna have a red button.
So in this case, I actually want to pass in null.
But if the next action is to turn this into a favorite,
then I want to have success as a color here,
which essentially is green so that the button looks a bit nicer with that simple change
if
we go back you see the button now is green and if i click it then
it's red because now we do have
this as a favorite and the next action is to unfavorite it which is kind of
a negative action
hence the button now is red only turning this into a favorite is green of course
feel free to
add more styles you could also change other styles for example set this here to a
green color if this
a favorite wherever you like now that is a nice first step i think we can
also improve the
experience here by adding a little badge after the title which tells us whether this is
a favorite or
not and for this we can add a new component batch svelte here and the batch
i'll create here it will
be very simple in the end this will simply be a span and in that span
here i will use a slot
and I will use a slot here because I want to be able to output any
text you want inside of this
batch and then just provide some styles here for the batch and we can quickly write
those together
since that won't be that many. I'll set the display to inline block here. I'll add
a margin
to left and right of .25rem, a border radius of three pixels here, and a border
of one pixel solid.
And then I'll dive into my header and take the red color from there because I
like that a lot.
So that is the color I want to use here as well. I'll also use that
red color as a background
and set a text color of white thereafter.
And also add some padding here of, let's say,
zero top and bottom, but .5rem left and right.
Now let's see how that looks like,
and let's go to the meetup item,
and first of all, import our component here.
So import batch from the UI folder,
and there from the batch svelte file.
With batch imported, let's go down,
and next to the title here inside of the h1 tag actually i will now add
batch and since i'm using
a slot we can add our text between the opening and closing tags now of course
this will not
always be rendered though this should only be rendered if we have this favorited so i'll
actually wrap it into a if check and check if is fav is true and only
if it is true only in that
case the badge should be rendered and then and in that case i'll then and insert
some content here
in between of course which should say favorite maybe all uppercase like this if you now
go back
and i favorite this we have this favorite badge next to it when it is a
favorite and actually
there are two changes i want to make to my badge styling here i'll set the
font family to lotto
fallback sent serif which are latos an extra custom style i'm importing and i'll also shrink
the font size to 1.8 rem so the 0.8 rem so that it's a
little bit smaller so now let's try this
again yeah that looks quite nice that is my little badge here now we can clearly
see if something is
a favorite or not